yes from the bahamas
i was just telling right like you know
people think we have we have an argument
beef that's not the case
i love russ i care about russ he's done
a lot for the game and when you're that
caliber player and you're not playing
well people take shots i don't like to
see people come with my guy like rust
like that so i'm watching i'm analyzing
i was like
i finally see his problem
like he wants to do so good he's going a
thousand miles an hour i said my man
slow down
you know like the one play he he starts
to fast break back there
and then he's fast but not as fast as
the old rust and then the young guy
caught up with him and turned on it's
like bro
take your time slow it down and then
explode don't give the guy time to react
like if you start back at 94 feet full
speed guy's going to turn he'll get
direct so i was just telling him bro
just slow down you know just take your
time so you said slow down how did he
respond
he was like man
man you know i'm just trying to get a
riddle i said no slow down slow your
game down pace yourself you don't have
to go many miles an hour